President Trump on Friday announcing
that churches and other houses of
worship should no longer need to abide
by the same restrictions that have
forced businesses across the country to
close during this pandemic some
governors have deemed to liquor stores
and abortion clinics is essential but
have left our churches and other houses
of worship it's now right so I'm
correcting this injustice and calling
houses of worship essential
I call upon governors to allow our
churches and places of worship to open
right now the president adding that if
governors of those states won't let
churches open he will override them so
it's still not clear if he has the
authority to do so joining us now Health
and Human Services Secretary Alex azar
secretary good morning thanks so much
for being here and happy Memorial Day to
you same to you Sandra and great to be
with you and your viewers thanks
absolutely it is Sunday morning Memorial
Day weekend and millions of Americans
across the country are waking up
wondering if it is safe to return to
their to their church or their place of
worship this morning you tell them what
well we believe it is as long as your
church is taking appropriate precautions
and we put out guidance to the to that
effect you know my my church back in
Indianapolis what are they doing there
there they've got appointments you sign
up so that they don't get overcrowded
you get screened for temperature as well
as symptoms as you come in you socially
distance among family units in the
church the church has been sanitized by
the cleaning workers there so we can get
back to work back to school and back to
worship and safe ways because of
president Trump's historic response here
secretary is our it has been fascinating
to see some of the accommodations that
church is made even during the shutdown
holding online services drive up
services etc the CDC guidelines have
been released we have some of them for
you up on the screen while they are
lengthy we we chose some of the most
important ones of course that is making
sanitizers and soaps handy for all the
parishioners that enter the building
wearing cloth masks keeping a high level
of cleanliness social distancing of
course and what struck me also was
limiting
the sharing of books and hymnals in pews
and chairs that are made available you
see the same thing with restaurants and
in menus they're going to have one time
menu so that you know people aren't
using the same things in front of them
the Washington Post this week was
reporting that the reason for the delay
in this guidance from the CDC on faith
based operations was because there was
disagreement between the CDC and the
White House are both in agreement on
those guidelines mr. secretary
yes yes they are you know there's an
iterative process that we engage in with
CDC the White House and other parts of
the interagency so just make sure
whatever we put out is as good as
possible you know it doesn't help a
priest a pastor and a mom a rabbi much
to get a 60 page single-spaced Public
Health document that that goes through
everything is if you have a master's in
epidemiology so we we put information
like that out also but we want to make
sure we put actionable understandable
information out to the leaders of faith
communities but also our summer camp
directors our school leaders and those
who run small businesses so so it's just
a process to make sure we're fitting our
information to our audience I want to
get to summer school and school in
general in just a moment as well as
those summer camps but first I want to
take this big picture because the FDA
Commissioner dr. Han this morning he put
out a statement and he essentially said
this virus is not contained yet and so
while we understand that millions of
Americans will be heading out to enjoy
Memorial Day services and celebrations
it is up to the individual to you as an
American to protect yourself and limit
the spread of this virus what is your
message this morning mr. secretary well
certainly I would endorse what dr. Han
had to say there but I would also add
that thanks to president Trump's and the
our governor's historic response to this
we have to and we can get back to work
to school to community to engagement
because it's not an issue of health
versus our economy it's actually an
issue of health versus health by being
locked up in our homes there's very real
health
secuence is the social and economic
dislocation leads to suicide and mental
illness we have hundreds of thousands of
fewer cancer screenings and treatments
going on we have less preventive
services millions of kids aren't getting
their pediatric vaccinations those are
real discernible immediate health
consequences that have to be considered
just as much as the spread of this
disease has to be considered we have
heard that warning from you secretary
azar but now dr. Fauci who once said at
a Capitol Hill hearing that he is only
looking at the science and the medical
side of things he is now putting out a
new warning in a new interview sounding
the alarm on shutting down and staying
shut down for too long
I'll throw his words up on the screen he
said this we can't stay lockdown for
such a considerable period of time that
you might do irreparable damage and have
unintended consequences included
consequences for health perhaps is this
a sign that dr. Falchi and others inside
the administration that task force team
itself might be seeing that some states
are taking their lock down and shut down
orders too far secretaries are well III
think doctor foul cheese a perspective
right there is very wise which is it
requires balance you know we took the
measures of shut down at the time
because the president out of the
circumstances those were the right
measures to recommend but now now that
we have the one of the world's best
testing systems more testing going on
than anywhere else in the world now that
we have our state's really in the
driver's seat with contact tracing
testing and isolation of cases and and
and seeking out and and containing
various outbreaks we have the tools to
get back up and running again in a safe
smart way and we just can't stay
lockdown forever as dr. Falchi said we
hear you and I know there's many
Americans who feel the same way about
that while wanting to still be safe and
stop the spread of this virus
that being said we've heard a lot of
that from President Trump and in a new
interview speaking to Maria Bartiromo
this week he not only sounds the alarm
about staying closed too long but he
also starts to point fingers and says
that there's politics at play here
here's the president your critics want
you to keep it closed going into the
election yeah I do I do I think it's a
it's a political thing in addition I
think you're putting money business
ahead of lives no no I think the people
that want to see the right thing
happened they agree with me we have to
get our country open secretary Hayes our
our politics at play and if politics
played any part in impeding your ability
to keep the country safe well I don't
want to get into any type of politics
discussion but I'll tell you this Sandra
I just had the pleasure of traveling on
commercial airlines down to North
Carolina and Florida this week North
Carolina led by Democratic governor
Cooper and Florida led by Republican
Governor to Santos and in both states
we're seeing reopening we're seeing
reopening in safe ways the coca-cola 600
is gonna run today NASCAR I got to see
the precautions that they're taking at
the Charlotte Speedway to make that
happen I got to be in Florida at the
Mayo Clinic to see how they're reopening
to get elective procedures back up and
running to do preventive care and make
sure people are getting the health care
they need and I just I think it's great
to see how we're working closely with
our governor's and and just helping to
bring this country back again all right
final thoughts because I just told our
viewers had asked you about it and you
asked parents anywhere in this country
right now they're wondering about summer
camps they're wondering about summer
school and most importantly they're
wondering about their kids returning to
school in the fall what can you tell us
about where you stand on whether or not
that's gonna happen well first and
foremost I would say to any parent judge
your individual circumstances first are
you your child or other household
members particularly vulnerable or at
risk because you've always got to be
looking out to protect your household
unit first in making these decisions
then I'd say follow the guidance of your
local leaders this is a locally lead
state supervised federally supported
we've put out guidance about schools and
summer camps getting reopen and safe
procedures to do so but as always your
local and state leaders know the
circumstances on the ground best follow
their guidance but I hope that we'll be
back at summer camp I hope we'll be back
at school again there are ways to do it
safely
we don't have to be in our houses to be
safe we can do this safely with the few
seconds I have left as far as a vaccine
you and I spoke earlier this week about
that are you optimistic as the White
House is that we could see one by end of
year this is a very credible objective
you know we just signed a deal with
Astra Zeneca for the Oxford vaccine
whereby October we could have a hundred
million doses of vaccine and 300 million
doses by early next year and we're gonna
place multiple bets like this and and
drive operation warp speed because the
president Trump has said he demands that
we reduce an efficiency in that system
when we get these kind of results if at
all possible
secretary Hayes I really appreciate your
time on this Memorial Day weekend thank
you prepare your Sunday morning with us